[Music]
so want to hear one of the most females
one of the title one of the most female
stories ever um okay this is from let me
guess it started off with i
i
i spent ten thousand pounds while manic
and my bank rode off the deck
i knew it
i spent ten thousand ten thousand pounds
while manic and my bank rode off the
debt
let's put her up on the screen i [ __ ]
knew it was going to start with i
there she is it always does it
it always does
after five years of law school training
at a prestigious law firm and practicing
as an associate solicitor
over a short space of time in november
2019 i decided to hand my resignation
buy a dog move on to a barge and take
out a loan of 10 000 pounds
the money was scarcely easy to access
too i applied through my banking app on
the evening of 11 pm with very few
questions asked about what i needed
that's the short the sword amount for so
she's already blaming them for giving
her the money i didn't speak to anyone
as part of the application process has
had this been a requirement nationwide
might have realized that something was
very wrong it's the bank's fault that
she did this and this is this is the
narrative okay
instead they're duly they do fully
appointed uh do fully approve my request
and over the next 10 days i spent it all
on absurd transactions in one evening
alone i spent 700
on plants and rugs for my new boat and
an additional 200
dollars buying the same top in eight
different colors
days later i contacted a carpenter and i
asked him to build bookshelves on my
boat while fitting these he explained
that he was in debt and couldn't feed
his four children and wife when he
finished the job i decided to pay him
for work and also give him additional
two thousand dollars so he could save
his family not her money
i told him he didn't have to worry about
paying me back at the time this all felt
perfectly rational then ironically i was
left destitute that's it's not irony
yeah that's how is that irony how is
that irony can i can i correct that yeah
incidentally i was left destitute yeah
there you go
that's that's not that's not how it
works
um
well you can see look she's normal
oh wow the cause of my erratic behavior
type one bipolar disorder oh
yeah of course
of which one of the many symptoms is
mania
not the wrestle kind the normal kind
what about bachelor mania
ew take it down psychology condition
that causes a person to experience
unreasonable euphoria intense moods of
hyperactivity and an inability to ever
take responsibility for anything they do
correct that's the main symptom uh we
also call it modern dating hey guys i'm
not responsible for the financial fraud
i engaged in or any of the people whose
lives i ruined
i'm sick
isn't that great isn't that a [ __ ]
great out why are people that bipolar
why are the majority of them women
because
they're lying and honestly women just
here's the thing most of you
don't don't have bipolar disorder most
of you women just do whatever the [ __ ]
you want and most you women just have
really poor selfish instincts
so um
because you feel more
you guys think that you're actually much
more sensitive and altruistic than men
are but the truth is is that you feel
whenever you feel like feeling but
whenever you're just doing some selfish
[ __ ] you're able to shut those emotions
off like a [ __ ] faucet um and then
when you want to get out of trouble you
can always find some upper west side
who will write you a script give you
basically absolve you of all your sins
without having to go to a church and
tell you it's okay
it's all right that you cheated on all
of your last boy every boyfriend you've
ever had it's okay that you've ripped
off banks you're sick
it's a sickness
one of the most prevalent side effects
is risky or impulsive behavior including
gambling and reckless spending before
2018 i was for all intents and purposes
a successful and ambitious person i
worked hard took pride in my
achievements and paid my taxes then for
reasons both genetic and environmental
uh bipolar rather than ambition began to
define me bipolar runs in my family my
grandma took her own life due to the
illness and my sister also suffers from
the disorder so she was genetically
predisposed however the stress of
sleeplessness and demands of my
corporate law acted as a catalyst
activating the illness and uh
cultivating accumulating in a diagnosis
in january 2018 and three and a half
weeks in a psychiatric facility
things consider the last name
no she's not a dupont i don't believe
things continue to get worse leading up
to 2019 episode which saw me apply for
the loan following that credit card
reminders interest fees and default
notices became part of my day-to-day
life the consequences of quitting law
just before the pandemic while
struggling with unprecedented disorder
uh pulled me into cycles of extreme
depression and civility eventually i was
forced to move back home with my parents
while living with them my mania subsided
and i thought i could apply for less
stressful roles in cafes or shops when
the pandemic restrictions eased yes
so when she
stopped having to support herself didn't
have to go to a job anymore she felt
better but also had to start living
under her parents house where if she
engaged in certain patterns of behavior
that she did outside of her parents
house she probably would have been
thrown out into the streets suddenly it
subsided is that what you're telling me
it's weird however in november 2020 my
mania returned in a heightened state i
found myself venturing to an abandoned
mental asylum in north wales i had
always been drawn to adapt dilapidated
buildings and decided uh and decided my
boyfriend and i should go explore you
mean your boyfriend should pay for it
yes okay my boyfriend and i had only
been together a few months at this point
and although he knew i had bipolar he
wasn't familiar enough with me or the
symptoms to question my erratic behavior
it's his fault again keep in mind in
this story it's the bank's fault it's
her family
it's pandemics
it's the boyfriend's fault i just seem
fun and spontaneous mania doesn't always
look like madness what's this broad's
name
her name is
dorothy hersen
dorothy herson
uh my boyfriend and i have been only
getting a few okay i had no fear for my
safety mania is marked by grandocity and
convictions
that one is invincible so despite the
fact that the walls were crumbling and
the floors were torn apart i felt uh
elated god-like even and climbed higher
and higher it never occurred to me that
i could be hurt the last thing i
remember was the rotting floor splitting
beneath my right foot i fell through the
picture
i fell through the floor crushing my
spine shattering my left foot and
sustaining among other things
uh a dislocation of my mid jaw of mid
tarsal joints
from which left being chronic pain
probably for the rest of my life
the prospect thank you of earning back
ten thousand dollars i owed had already
been slim but following my injury i felt
non-existent after being discharged i
could barely leave my bed without help
the notion of waitressing was a fantasy
job applications were met with
rejections while the default notices
demanded repayment and the money i will
continue to stack up
uh anyone who has been made bankrupt can
probably relate to the unbearable
feeling of shame and fear
though uh i knew my insolvency was
direct consequences of my bipolar
remember not her action her disease uh i
didn't mean to kill those kids i was
drunk
i didn't tell any of my friends family
or my boyfriend about my debt i was
terrified that he would find out or
worse that they would try to help me
i couldn't bear the shame
of them doing so so the shame of
unpayable debts being
relocated from the bank to my people i
loved uh
debt related stress is a particular
blend of anxiety and paralysis i was
overcome with panic because the debts
were so enormous and unpayable i would
avoid
thinking of talking about them or doing
anything that would remind me of the
existence if i engaged with the debt i
would become suicidal i would think
there is nothing i can do there's no
other way out i was helpless to change
my circumstances i lay in bed lying in
my bed for weeks
went by applying for low stress
non-physical jobs so she had all this
money that she had but she also didn't
want to apply for any jobs that made
money
by christmas 2020 i found myself
sobbing to my doctor explaining that i
was suicidal and feared that i would not
make it through the year
this doctor referred me to a
psychiatrist agreed to change my
medication to see if it reversed
uh if a revised combination could help
improve my mood and call me regularly
over the period
so just over a year after taking out a
loan i had become too unwell to
correspond directly with my bank
and so i finally broke down and told my
mom everything i relinquished my control
over my accounts to my mom who having
two daughters with bipolar was now used
to the problem in the accompanying
conditions
um let's see here corporate attitudes
corporate attitudes are mental health
illness are slowly shifting quiet
recognition of okay i'm trying to get to
the part where they wrote it off i do
like that the the
uh it says mum would intercept default
notices for fear they would push me
so
you
made it as i predicted at the beginning
of this article you've made a huge mess
of everything your mother's life your
family's life
uh you stole from the which by the way
i'm not crying for the bank but you
didn't no i'm not you stole from the
bank
um you
drove this poor boyfriend [ __ ] insane
uh you've done everything the way you
want to do it on your terms and now that
you've [ __ ] everything up like any
other white woman
i'm tired and then just you deal with
all this i have to go lay down my
fibromyalgia is acting up you know what
i mean and you're gonna be milking that
fake ass injury forever now
god white women are just the worst mom
would intercept depth notices for fear
that they pushed me to suicide she
eventually took up the correspondence
with the bank on my behalf and in a
desperate attempt forwarded my health
records onto them and hoped that they
would alleviate the pressure to return
the money she sent them both psychiatric
reports expressing concern of our mental
state and physical reports of dealing
with injuries we didn't know how much
hope this uh this would would work but
we thought it was worth a try however my
utter disbelief nationwide wrote to my
mother a few months later agreeing to
write off all my debts on the basis of
mental health they confirmed that the
debt would not be recorded as a
bankruptcy for credit purposes on
hearing this the past 18 months just
[ __ ] this [ __ ] you know why i'm mad at
this because there's there's people that
took out loans that run businesses in
your country in our country right and
the government shut up down and you know
what they're not doing these banks
aren't forgiving the loans of people
that own a mom-and-pop shop right
they're not doing that they're not
forgiving the loans of those people that
actually would have worked if they were
allowed to right they should have closed
their businesses down before covering
them got a boat yeah that's my point so
this [ __ ] goes because oh oh my like
you said oh my god i'm sleepy i can't
pay off my debts and then there's people
that are trying to provide for their
family and then the [ __ ] government
shut down their business and are the
banks gonna forgive their loans oh no of
course not on hearing that the past 18
months of stress and fear began and
subsided though i still don't feel
confident
managing my finances i'm aware that
someone think it happened again uh this
is a milestone
and we really do enjoy the system is
changing to accommodate us this is a pro
system article this is another one that
the banks are the heroes
but i mean
[ __ ] her you don't feel
any shame like you wrote this story and
you're bragging about like you're
bragging about this yeah she's bragging
this is a positive thing for her you're
bragging this is like that scene in the
big short when uh when a guy goes up to
steve carell and he's like i don't
understand it why are these guys
confessing and he's like do you not get
it they're not confessing they're
bragging
i guess it's literally like
they're not even
they're just bragging at this point
i have a question with this sure whole
thing
so she she gave up control to her mother
right yeah her mom her mom her mom
but didn't she say before that this
whole bipolar thing is hereditary
yeah so isn't her mom also bipolar no
her sister and her grandmother right so
i guess the mom of god it's a generation
okay okay which i always love when they
say that like oh yeah you know the mom
was spared the mental illness oh no
that's great now that mom has to take
care of all these other [ __ ] burdens
yeah i'd rather have the mental illness
uh that's why jim brewer has bags under
his eyes